have you ever wondered what makes Amish
life so unique today I'll take you
inside their world horsedrawn buggies a
life of Simplicity and the care of
millions of chickens these are some of
the things that define the Amish way of
life while they're renowned for adhering
to traditional Customs there's an
unexpected aspect of their culture that
many aren't aware of their flourishing
poultry industry the Amish rais an
astonishing number of chickens annually
producing both meat and eggs all while
maintaining a lifestyle that avoids
modern technology picture a world
without electricity or Machinery yet
thriving with an industrious Spirit
that's the Unique Reality of Amish
poultry farming for Amish farmers
raising chickens is a harmonious blend
of age-old traditions and thoughtful
agricultural practices one key element
of their success lies in selecting the
right chicken breeds a lot of
consideration goes into choosing birds
that will thrive in their specific
environments while providing optimal
results whether for eggs or meat let's
explore some of the most favorite
chicken breeds among the Amish each
breed carries its own distinct charm and
purpose first on the list is the Rhode
Island red a popular breed valued for
its exceptional egg laying capabilities
these birds are not only reliable
producers of about 250 to 300 eggs
annually but are also known for their
friendly nature and resilience with
their vibrant red plumage and sturdy
build they are like the Dependable
workhorses of the chicken world they're
easy to care for and require nothing
more than a simple Co-op and some space
to roam to keep them content then
there's the Cornish cross the Superstar
of meat chicken farming these birds are
bred specifically for their rapid growth
and efficiency incredibly a Cornish
cross can reach Market size within just
6 to 8 weeks making them an industry
favorite their quick growth tender meat
and ideal size for the dinner table make
them indispensable for Amish farmers
choosing the right breed is not just
about productivity it's also about
sustainability Amish farmers are keenly
aware of how each breed affects their
farming ecosystem they rotate their
flocks introducing different breeds to
diversify their stock and maintain the
health of their poultry this approach is
like hosting a rotating lineup in a
grand chicken performance with layers
broilers and Dual Purpose breeds all
playing a role this careful planning
ensures a steady supply of eggs and meat
while keeping their flocks healthy and
well balanced to house their chickens
the Amish construct coups that are
practical durable and thoughtfully
designed these traditional CS are often
made from solid wood built to last for
years proper ventilation is a critical
feature ensuring that the air inside
stays fresh and comfortable for the
birds after all no one wants to live in
a stifling space just ask anyone who
spent a summer in an unventilated room
space is another crucial consideration
in Amish chicken coups chickens need
room to move scratch the ground and
stretch their wings imagine being
crammed into a tiny space with no room
to maneuver is hardly a recipe for a
happy life a well-designed co-op
provides the chickens with a spacious
and safe environment where they can
relax and Thrive happier chickens after
all mean better eggs sustainability is a
guiding principle in Amish farming and
this extends to how they build their CPS
often they use reclaimed materials like
old Barnwood or wooden pallets giving
each Cooper rustic eco-friendly charm
these upcycled coups not only reduce
waste but also reflect the Amish
commitment to living in harmony with the
environment Beyond Aesthetics the coups
are designed to protect the chickens
from predators such as foxes and
raccoons additional features like
nesting boxes lined with soft bedding
ensure that the hens have a cozy and
comfortable place to lay their eggs who
wouldn't want a plush comfy spot for
such an important task cleanliness is
another top priority for Amish farmers
their coups often include removable
floors or trays making it easy to clean
and maintain a healthy environment for
the chickens a clean Coupe keeps pests
at Bay and ensures that the birds remain
happy and healthy when it comes to
feeding their chickens the Amish r on
simple natural methods forget process
feed these farmers use grains kitchen
scraps and whatever the chickens can
forage from the land it's like a daily
buffet for the birds offering them a
variety of nutrients grains such as corn
wheat and oats form the foundation of
their diet providing the protein and
energy that chickens need to thrive food
scraps are also a key part of their
feeding system leftovers from family
meals often become the chicken's next
Feast turning what might otherwise go to
waste into a nutritious streat for the
flock growing up it was always
fascinating to see how these birds
transformed kitchen scraps into Rich
flavorful eggs and meat a true Testament
to the Amish commitment to
sustainability and resourcefulness
kitchen scraps such as vegetable peels
stale bread and even leftover pasta find
a second life in the chicken yard there
the chickens eagerly Peck at the
offerings as if they were Gourmet chefs
however one thing to avoid feeding them
is chocolate while chickens can consume
a wide range of foods chocolate is
extremely toxic to them just as it is to
humans and could lead to severe health
issues for the flock here's something
even more fascinating Amish chickens are
allowed to roam freely to forage for
food this means they hunt for bugs grass
weeds and anything else they can uncover
with their feet or snag with their beaks
not only does this natural foraging
Behavior Keep the chickens active and
entertained but it also provides them
with high quality protein and essential
vitamins interestingly this diet
benefits more than just the chickens it
has a significant impact on their eggs
as well a diverse diet results in eggs
that are richer in flavor and have
vibrant yolks that's why eggs from Freer
ranging foraging chicken stand out in
taste and quality compared to those
you'd find in a typical store for the
Amish egg production is both a practical
science and a cherished tradition just
like other living creatures chickens
Thrive when their needs are met and
light plays a crucial role in their egg
laying process hens rely on a consistent
light cycle to regulate their laying by
mimicking the natural patterns of
daylight Amish farmers signal to the
hen's bodies when it's time to start
producing eggs Amish coups are carefully
designed to let in ample natural light
even during the shorter days of winter
this attention to detail ensures a
consistent eggs Supply year round did
you know a single healthy hen can lay
about 300 eggs annually that means
owning just three hens could provide
nearly 1,000 eggs a year plenty for
family meals baking projects and special
treats as a child I remember how our
household always seemed to have more
eggs than we knew what to do with my
mother would bake cakes prepare custard
and on special occasions whip up deviled
eggs that were gone in seconds Amish egg
production isn't just for personal
consumption though eggs are also a vital
part of their local economy eggs from
Amish farms are prized for their
exceptional freshness they are often
sold or Bartered within the community or
at local markets my grandfather used to
joke that eggs were as good as cacy
among the Amish and in some ways he
wasn't wrong there's something uniquely
satisfying about buying egg at a market
knowing they were laid just ours earlier
however producing such highquality eggs
isn't just left to chance Alish farmers
pay close attention to their hens laying
Cycles coups are strategically
positioned to capture as much natural
light as possible even in the depths of
winter Stress Management is another key
factor since a stressed hen won't lay
eggs consistently in Amish farms the
hens live in calm and quiet environments
without the noise of heavy machinery
some farmers even swear by playing
soothing classical music in the coups
claiming it helps the hens lay Mor eggs
whether or not that's scientifically
proven the eggs from those hens are
always exceptional the hen diet is
another crucial element a varied diet of
grains insects and kitchen scraps
ensures that the eggs are rich and
flavorful even the yolks take on a deep
orange Hue a sign of freshness and
quality my grandfather used to say you
could tell how happy a hen was by the
quality of her eggs and he wasn't wrong
there's a noticeable difference in both
taste and appearance although it might
look like the hens are laying eggs at
their Leisure a lot of effort goes on
behind the scenes to maintain consistent
egg production from managing natural
light and diet to creating stress-free
living conditions the Amish have
perfected The Art of Keeping their hands
in optimal shape for laying when you
think about how many eggs these methods
yield it's no surprised that Amish
farming techniques have stood the test
of time the journey from foraging
chicken to Fresh laid egg is a carefully
managed process that reflects a deep
understanding of Nature and tradition
when these chickens hatch they begin a
life that any bird would dream of having
Amish farmers are widely recognized for
their ethical and compassionate
practices in raising animals and
chickens are no exception these birds
enjoy the freedom to roam Outdoors
exploring Fields scratching for bugs and
foraging for Natural Treats in an
environment most chickens would envy if
there were ever a fitness plan for
chickens this would be it complete with
exercise and an array of delicious
snacks while conventional meat chicken
farming often focuses on confinement and
rapid weight gain the Amish follow a
unique path sure the goal remains to
raise chickens for the dinner table but
they do so by ensuring the birds live a
natural and low stress lifestyle unlike
commercial poultry operations where
chickens are crammed into small spaces
Amish chickens enjoy the luxury of
stretching their legs wandering freely
and quite literally building stronger
drumsticks the result healthier chickens
with robust growth that produce meat of
exceptional flavor and quality it's like
free- range chicken farming but with a
distinctive Amish touch my grandfather
used to joke that if these chickens wore
step counters they'd likely outpace the
steps I took as a child and honestly he
wasn't wrong but it's not just about
keeping the birds active the Amish
meticulously manage the entire life
cycle of their chickens from hatchling
to the dinner table ensuring they grow
both naturally and efficiently Seasons
play a crucial role in how these birds
are raised during the warmer months the
chickens enjoy the Bounty of lush fields
which are alive with insects grasses and
every other treat a chicken could wish
for it's like an all you can eat buffet
in nature and the chickens happily
indulge waddling around in sunlet Bliss
if you're enjoying this don't forget to
like comment and subscribe to Freshly
laid egg is a carefully managed process
that reflects a deep understanding of
Nature and tradition when these chickens
hatch they begin a life that any bird
would dream of having Amish farmers are
widely recognized for their ethical and
compassionate practices in raising
animals and chickens are no exception
these birds enjoy the freedom to roam
Outdoors exploring Fields scratching for
bugs and foraging for Natural Treats in
an environment most chickens would envy
if there were ever a fitness plan for
chickens this would be incomplete with
exercise and an array of delicious
snacks while conventional meat chicken
farming often focuses on confinement and
rapid weight gain the Amish follow a
unique path sure the goal remains to
raise chickens for the dinner table but
they do so by ensuring the birds live a
natural and low stress lifestyle unlike
commercial poultry operations where
chickens are crammed into small spaces
Amish chickens enjoy the luxury of
stretching their legs wandering freely
and quite literally building stronger
drumsticks the result healthier chickens
with robust growth that produce meat of
exceptional flavor and quality it's like
Freer range chicken farming but with a
distinctive Amish touch my grandfather
used to joke that if these chickens wore
step counters they'd likely outpace the
steps I took as a child and honestly he
wasn't wrong but it's not just about
keeping the birds active the Amish
meticulously manage the entire life
cycle of their chickens from hatchling
to the dinner table ensuring they grow
both naturally and efficiently Seasons
play a crucial role in how these birds
are raised during the warmer months the
chickens enjoy the Bounty of lush fields
which are alive with insects grasses and
every other treat a chicken could wish
for it's like an all you can eat buffet
in nature and the chicken happily
indulge waddling around in sunlet Bliss
however as winter sets in the conditions
for foraging change significantly
chickens can't be expected to scratch
through the snow which is where the
Amish showcased their resourcefulness
the birds are moved into insulated cozy
shelters that Shield them from the cold
while their outdoor roaming is
temporarily paused their diet is
carefully adjusted to maintain their
health and growth almost like switching
from an outdoor gym to a warm indoor
Fitness routine if you've ever visited
an Amish farm in the winter you'd see
how nothing goes to waste even chicken
manure is put to good use as fertilizer
for next year's crops exemplifying the
Amish commitment to sustainability in
every aspect of their farming practices
so how did the chickens remain content
despite the seasonal shifts the secret
lies in keeping things as natural and
stress-free as possible when animals are
treated with care they grow better and
for chickens that means their meat
tastes better too the Amish philosophy
ensures their chickens enjoy the best
quality of life whether it's during
summer winter or anywhere in between the
key to the Amish method is balance
allowing the birds plenty of room for
Ram ample Sunshine during during the
warmer months and a stress-free
protected environment year round they're
never hurried or confined to cramped
spaces and this makes all the difference
in the quality of life for the chickens
and the flavor of their meat my
grandfather always said a Happy Chicken
makes for a Happy Meal and after tasting
Amish raised chickens I can confidently
say he was right one of the most
remarkable aspects of Amish chicken
farming is its strong foundation in
Tradition the methods they use today
have been handed down through gener
ations and are still as effective as
they were a hundred years ago these
practices have endured because they
align with nature rather than working
against it providing chickens with
active fulfilling lives before they are
part of a family meal unlike Supermarket
bought Birds these chickens are raised
with compassion and sustainability which
results in healthier better tasting meat
but perhaps the most heartwarming part
of Amish chicken farming isn't just
their Care for Animals sit their care
for one another Amish farms oper operate
as a community effort where
collaboration is at the heart of
everything they do from construction to
sharing feed Amish farmers rely on their
neighbors in a way that exemplifies the
power of teamwork this sense of
community extends even to chicken
processing which is a collective event
rather than a factory operation Amish
families often gather for chicken
processing days where Neighbors come
together to help it's akin to a barn
raising but this time with feathers
picture a large open area filled with
tables neighbors arriving with their
chickens and a day full of work and
camaraderie it's not all about Labor
though it's also a time for sharing
laughter stories and plenty of
light-hearted chicken related humor the
classic why did the chicken cross the
road might be overused elsewhere but it
never fails to bring a laugh among the
Amish community neighbors begin arriving
each bringing their chickens in toe
ready for a productive day ahead while
there's certainly a lot of work to do
the atmosphere is far from solemn it's
filled with laughter stories and plenty
of time to catch up with friends of
course the humor flows as freely as the
tasks with chicken related jokes making
the rounds even the old classic why did
the chicken cross the road still earns a
chuckle in this setting particularly
after hours of feather plucking these
chicken processing days operate like a
woil machine proving the adage many
hands make light work each person takes
on a specific role one might be in
charge of handling the bird Birds
another focused on cleaning While others
assist with packaging the meat or
sorting feathers remarkably even the
feathers don't go to waste finding new
life as pillow stuffing or even
insulation every task is shared ensuring
no one feels overburdened by the end of
the day fames head home with fresh
processed chicken while everyone departs
with a sense of fulfillment what's truly
remarkable about these events is the
Cooperative spirit that has been
cultivated and passed down through
generations this isn't merely about
completing a task it's about
strengthening the ties between families
it's the kind of camarad that leaves
everyone feeling both tired and deeply
satisfied like after a hard day of
meaningful work with loved ones for the
Amish these gatherings are about more
than producing food there about
nurturing the soul even with their
knowledge and teamwork Amish chicken
farmers face a host of challenges in
their trade if raising chickens seems
simple just feeding them grain and gas
weing eggs think again the Amish deal
with issues like weather extremes
disease prevention and unpredictable
Market shifts all of which contest even
the most experienced Farmers let's start
with the weather a factor entirely out
of their control but one they must
navigate harsh Winters in Amish Country
don't just require people to bundle up
Farmers must ensure their chicken stay
warm too a sudden cold snap can reduce
egg production quicker than you'd
imagine that's why Amish farmers build
well insulated CPS to keep their Birds
comfortable through the frigid months
conversely during The Heat Of Summer
keeping chickens cool becomes just as
critical chickens aren't exactly fans of
extreme heat especially while alive
Farmers must ensure their flocks remain
hydrated and maintain proper ventilation
when raising hundreds or even thousands
of birds managing their comfort can feel
like aroundthe clock responsibility each
season brings its own unique hurdles and
the Amish with their deep respect for
nature have learned to adapt to these
everchanging
circumstances but weather isn't the only
challenge on their radar disease is
another major concern particularly given
that animals live in close quarters just
as illnesses can spread quickly among
humans chickens are no different to
prevent outbreaks the Amish don't rely
on conventional methods like antibiotics
but instead use natural remedies and
holistic care practices herbs and other
traditional techniques play play a big
role in maintaining the health of their
flocks their coups are kept impeccably
clean often cleaner than some City
dwellings with rigorous routines to
ensure hygiene however even the most
diligent efforts can't entirely
eliminate the risk of disease when
sickness does strike quick action is
critical Farmers focus on containment to
prevent the illness from spreading to
the rest of the flock fun fact just like
humans sick chickens can be ficky eaters
they might turn their beaks up at their
usual feed when they're under the
weather luckily the Amish have a variety
of Creative Solutions to encourage their
Birds to eat even if it's not their
favorite snack then there's the issue of
Market fluctuations predicting the price
of eggs or chickens at the local market
is never straightforward prices can
swing dramatically depending on the
season consumer demand or broader
National Trends one month Amish farmers
might enjoy high prices for their free
range eggs and the next they might finds
struggling to turn a profit but Amish
farmers are nothing if not resilient
their simple Frugal Lifestyles and
careful planning allow them to weather
economic ups and downs during good times
they save and reinvest in their Farms
while during tougher periods they
tighten their budgets and push forward
with determination despite these
challenges the Amish maintain a sense of
humor they know that sometimes laughter
is the best way to cope with
difficulties one light-hearted joke
often Shar in Amish communities is why
did the chicken cross the road to check
the market price on the other side it's
these small moments of humor that help
them stay grounded and optimistic even
when the road gets rough sometimes the
best way to handle a new challenge is
simply to laugh about it in Amish
communities there's a popular joke that
captures this light-heartedness why did
the chicken cross the road to check the
market price on the other side it's one
of those small but cheerful ways they
manage to stay positive even when life
doesn't go as planned the lesson here
don't let a chicken cross the road
unless it has it worth while purpose
perhaps market trends are reason enough
this humor reflects the Amish way of
navigating difficulties with Grace
what's truly inspiring is their
resilience over generations of farming
they've faced everything from extreme
weather and disease outbreaks to
economic downturns yet they continue to
endure and Thrive their approach to
farming is grounded in values like
simplic
diligence and patience it's never about
quick Solutions but rather about
creating something lasting when faced
with a problem they don't get
overwhelmed instead they unite devise a
plan and move forward it's a mindset
that anyone could learn from there's
something refreshing about how the Amish
tackle challenges whether it's
unpredictable weather or fluctuating
market prices they refuse to let bad
days Define them instead they view
obstacles as opportuni to innovate and
work harder and sometimes they lighten
the mood with a good laugh Beyond being
Farmers they are problem solvers always
anticipating and overcoming whatever
comes their way this is why Amish
chicken farming continues to flourish no
matter what nature or the economy throws
at them their farming practices are more
than just a livelihood they embody a
sustainable way of life that's passed
down through generations their methods
aren't modern Trends but traditional
practices refined over centuries countes
a Cornerstone of their sustainable
approach is Land Management for instance
crop rotation is one of their key
strategies for keeping the soil fertile
by planting different crops each year
corn one season soybeans the next day
prevent nutrient depletion it's a
natural way to let the soil rejuvenate
chickens play a crucial role too as they
scratch the ground and forage they
naturally fertilize the soil the Amish
avoid synthetic fertilizers and
chemicals relying instead on this
balanced natural cycle another important
aspect of their sustainability is Waste
Management raising hundreds of chickens
inevitably means dealing with a lot of
manure but instead of seeing it as a
problem the Amish view it as an
opportunity by mixing chicken manure
with straw and other organic materials
they create Rich compost this compost is
then used to fertilize their fields
creating a closed loop system where
nothing is wasted of course not
everything goes perfectly one amusing
story involves a young Amish farmer
experimenting with composting he had
built a large pile of compost in his
yard and thought it would be helpful to
let his chickens roam freely around it
to help break it down however he didn't
anticipate how enthusiastic the chickens
would be before long they had spread the
compost all over the yard turning it
into a massive mess it took him most of
the day to clean it up the lesson while
chickens and compost are a great
combination they can cause chaos if not
carefully managed sustainability for the
Amish isn't just about immediate
benefits it's about the future they
Place great importance on passing down
their farming knowledge and practices to
the Next Generation it's common to see
children as young as five or six helping
on the farm learning from their Elders
by the time they're teenagers they're
already skilled in techniques like crop
rotation chicken care and composting
it's not just about running a farm it's
about preserving a way of life that has
endured for centuries what's remarkable
is that the Amish continue to use
traditional methods despite modern
technological advancements while it
might be easier to use tractors or
chemical fertilizers they choose not to
for the Amish farming is about Steward
ship carrying for the land and animals
in a way that honors their faith and
ensures sustainability for future
Generations their philosophy is like
planting a tree today knowing that it
will provide shade for their
grandchildren Community is also an
essential part of their approach
sustainability isn't an individual
effort it's a collective one neighbors
help one another whether it's with
composting or rotating crops this Spirit
of cooperation not only strengthens
their farming practices but also deepens
their communal bonds the Amish model of
sustainability is something the rest of
the world could learn from while many of
us are trying to figure out how to live
more sustainably and reduce our carbon
Footprints the Amish have been quietly
practicing the these principles for
Generations they're not looking for
recognition or awards they're simply
doing what they've always done taking
care of the land so it can take care of
them in return